first things first respect to the
research team for finding this hilarious
movie in the opening scene a drunk woman
is crying to a religious totem pole
because she hasn't been touched by a man
in a long time she hits the pole's face
breaking a piece of wood that looks like
a nose suddenly lightning strikes making
the nose erect several naked men come
out of the wood and grant her the wish
all night long years later the emperor
of an eastern korean region is telling
the story to a councilman the broken
piece of the nose has been a valuable
artifact ever since but the emperor
accidentally touches it seductively
triggering its power a few minutes later
the councilman and the emperor limp out
of the chamber the emperor throws the
nose into the streets scared that it
will be triggered again eventually it is
found by a woman who wonders what the
nose is used for all of a sudden the
village is surrounded by half-naked men
who grab every adult they can to make
love they don't even spare the poor
animals and leave the village a mess
when everything calms down an old priest
performs a ritual on the sacred nose it
is put into a wine bottle and buried
deep into the ground everyone in the
village promises to never talk about the
incident again and it is soon forgotten
then we are introduced to a town in the
northern region where the women are the
breadwinners of the family they make all
the important decisions while men are
expected to take care of the babies and
do household work in this village the
primary responsibility of a man is to
satisfy their wives every night for
hours for the same reason all married
men are constantly tired and cannot work
outside of the house lucky buggers one
day a group of thugs from another
village are enjoying a meal at a local
restaurant they pick a fight with beyond
a guy in his twenties who sells rice
cakes for a living initially beyond
keeps quiet controlling his anger to the
best of his abilities but when the thugs
cross a line he single-handedly beats
them all a group of women watches him
closely discussing how lengthy his
weapon must be an older lady laughs at
them for assuming such an absurd thing
because she knows beyond has no game
inside his pants as she tells them the
story of how she found out we are taken
to a flashback one night beyond was
selling rice cakes as usual when he came
across a woman bathing out in the open
she called him into the tub and
proceeded to undress him but it turned
out he had a straw-sized penis the women
laugh and start looking at beyond in a
different light he is known in his
village for being impotent when it comes
to certain matters beyond cannot argue
because he knows it is true hopefully
beyond will find magic for his penis
soon in the following scene we are
introduced to beyond's older brother
kang mok unlike beyond kang mok is known
for being a manly man who could satisfy
any woman's needs but chooses not to
when he goes into the river to bathe a
group of women of all ages gathers to
watch him they long for a man with his
assets and have tried everything to
seduce him but nothing works on kang
mock later that night beyond is in a
restaurant drinking in misery a man
touches him inappropriately to check if
the rumors are true which causes a fight
between them kangmak quickly comes to
his brother's rescue and carries him
home on their way they encounter a woman
named dal gang dancing on a bridge
mesmerized by her beauty they fall into
the water she walks away right after but
her performance keeps playing in both of
their minds while drying their clothes
kangmak recounts the day when his
brother's genitals shrunk because of a
mistake what most people don't know is
that beyond was born with a normal penis
but when he was 19 his pants lit on fire
and took his underwear with it to stop
the fire kang mock repeatedly kicked him
in the nuts it saved beyond's life but
confirmed that he will never have a
child the brother's relationship hasn't
been the same since the incident but no
matter how much they fight at the end of
the day they always have each other's
back too bad they don't also have each
other's penis the next day beyond
overhears a bunch of guys talking about
dao gang she just moved to the village
but has managed to catch everyone's
attention rumor has it that she bathes
in the river every night at 8 pm the
group decides to watch her later that
day beyond also joins them and is made
fun of since he can watch beautiful
girls all day long but cannot do
anything about it soon dal gang arrives
and blows them away with her beauty she
accidentally loses her sandal in the
water and the men jump hoping to be the
one to help her at last she gets the
sandal herself and walks away the next
morning dalgang wakes up to a box of
food outside her hut she devours it
thankful to whoever put it there later
that day she catches beyond placing a
similar box this time with flowers in
front of the hut dal gang decides to
take an early swim today and is spotted
by another group of perverted men they
cannot get their eyes off her body but
are soon caught by their wives instead
of talking to their husbands the women
attack dao gang for trying to seduce
married men kang mok who is cutting wood
nearby sees this and runs to save her
from the lunatics after everything calms
down they make friends with each other
and share a brief conversation later at
night kang mok tells his brother to
start preparing for a wedding because he
has found a wife for himself the wife
turns out to be none other than dal gang
heartbroken by the news beyond storms
away he goes to the bridge and drowns in
his thoughts somewhere nearby the old
priest and his disciple are trapped in a
net set of wild animals they have been
tangled for hours and need immediate
help beyond hears them and saves their
lives the priest listens to beyond's
concerns and suggests a way he can
reverse his impotence and become the
best woman pleaser in the entire country
beyond is asked to drink only a sip of
wine from the bottle that was buried
with the sacred nose long ago the priest
continues explaining the consequences of
drinking more than a sip but beyond is
no longer interested he digs the wine
out of the ground finishes the entire
bottle and passes out drunk for more
than a day when he wakes up again even
little insects and wild mushrooms are
attracted to his crotch on his way home
he found out every man in the village
has been drafted to war but he missed
the draft since he was drunk because of
this he is the only man left in the
village in kangmak's absence he is to
take care of the house the business and
most importantly kangmak's wife at night
beyond cooks food for his sister-in-law
and accidentally walks in on her
sleeping in an erotic position because
of his newly repaired genitals he has a
hard time controlling himself to get rid
of the sex drive he chops wood the
entire night and drinks a pond dry as
expected he has to pee after drinking so
much water which is when he finds out
his new penis is basically a fire hose
at the same time the princess and her
guards are passing through the jungle
below the hill chaos ensues when a
wildfire spreads and people start to run
but they are ultimately saved when
beyond puts out the fire by urinating
from the top of the hill not just that
but at one point he urinates on the sun
and dims its light for a second the
women in the village are sick of
spending their nights alone because of
their husband's absence hence on hearing
news about the new and powerful manhood
they all grow excited a bar woman who
saw the water hose action tells everyone
else about it using a fish as an example
but the women will only believe it when
they see beyond's equipment with their
own eyes at night they gather outside
his house and spy on him the man seems
to be juggling a piece of cloth but both
his hands are by his sides and his legs
don't leave the ground the group's
suspicions are proven to be true when
beyond turns around displaying himself
in all his glory the next time beyond
goes out to sell the rice cakes he
encounters several women trying to
seduce him some are more subtle while
others flash him directly still beyond
keeps his stance and controls himself
one night the bar woman loses her
patience and breaks into his house
determined to make love to him beyond
senses her attraction and claims that
she cannot handle him in retaliation the
bar woman laughs because she has been
with more men than there is hair on his
head beyond takes it as a challenge and
rocks her night the noise wakes the
entire village and in a few minutes a
crowd of women comes to his house
waiting for their turn to get in bed
with him when he is done with the bar
woman she gets a nosebleed she proudly
claims that she will need at least 10
business days to recover one after
another every woman in the village is
pleased by beyond but his stamina never
runs out he doesn't differentiate
between the young and the old ones and
treats them all with the same amount of
love by the morning he has had
intercourse with every single woman in
the village except dal gang in the next
scene the princess tells the emperor
about the unnaturally long genitals in
the town the emperor makes his guard
kidnap beyond and bring him to the
palace let me get a look at this dick
says the emperor he is then given a
chance to free his brother and bring him
back from the war all he has to do is
participate in a weightlifting
competition and win but the kick is that
he cannot use his hands to carry the
weight beyond accepts the challenge and
goes against the champion of the lifting
competition initially he struggles
because he isn't aroused the princess
realizes this and gives him a push by
eating a banana seductively after
watching her beyond hoists several
kilograms of weight and wins the
competition as promised the soldiers go
to the war zone to bring kangmak back
but they do not find him which means he
must have died depressed about his
brother's death beyond refuses to talk
to anyone making the women thirsty for
his love again they try to catch his
attention time and again but nothing
works simultaneously the village is hit
by the worst drought of the decade the
scarcity of water and food makes dalgang
sick after a week of fighting the
disease she is on the verge of death no
doctor has a way to save her but one day
beyond calls a spiritual monk to his
house the man suggests that the only way
to save dalgang is for someone to make
love to her since kang mok is dead he
thinks it won't be a problem for beyond
to take responsibility beyond thinks
about it for hours before finally making
love to dal gang at night like the monk
had predicted she feels a lot better the
next day the old priest and the emperor
are worried about the drought that is
starting to kill people from starvation
the priest reveals that the sacred
female bear who lives in the woods is
not happy with the people of the empire
hence she has brought drought upon them
as punishment time for beyond to diddle
that bear to satisfy her one must
sacrifice their life to her back in the
village all women get sick at the same
time including dal gang and find out
they are pregnant with beyond's children
at the same time their husbands return
from war but are not told about what
happened in their absence a few days
pass but the women are no longer
satisfied with their husband's sex
drives then one day kang mock returns
from the war revealing that he lost a
leg the men also discovered that their
wives have been impregnated by beyond
unable to face his brother and everyone
else beyond volunteers to be the
sacrifice the village needs to end the
drought the women weep at the loss of
such a magnificent man but the officials
have already made the decision beyond
enters the cave with the bear and waits
to be attacked some time passes but the
rain never comes everyone assumes that
the ritual failed and that beyond
sacrificed his life for nothing but then
we see beyond making love to the sacred
bear satisfying her in a different way
than the priest wanted him to the plan
works and the village is blessed with
heavy rainfall the scene then cuts to a
few years later the tale of the
legendary libido is still narrated
around the country beyond sons have
grown up and have inherited water hose
power from their father in the last
scene the princess is on a boat telling
her friends about the time she met the
one and only sexual legend the man
rowing the boat turns around and reveals
that he is the said legend that boat is
gonna rock
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching